[Music]
we begin in Niger where reports are
emerging that the military regime will
prosecute the ousted president Muhammad
basum for high treason that's according
to a statement released by the military
Council Al jazeera's Ahmad Idris has
more from katsina in Northern Nigeria
the statement is an indication that the
military isn't about to let president
Mohammed basil go you know the
International Community especially
Echoes and the African Union their first
demand was to be released and along with
members of his family and other cabinet
members who have been arrested earlier
in the days of the coup so the statement
put out in the evening late evening on
Sunday by the military
shows that they want to put him on trial
and with the charges uh kind of amadu
abdulrahman put out on television this
could be serious charges that could of
course result in a very very serious
repercussions for president Mohammed
bazook it's certainly going to uh
increase tension between the government
in Nigeria the military government in
Nigeria and the International Community
especially the economic community of
West African States some analysts could
see this as possibly as an attempt by
the military to further strengthen their
hands and future negotiations but again
I remember there have been some rumors
about the possibility of taking serious
uh steps against Muhammad balzum earlier
uh in the days of the coup so for that
it's hard to say exactly what they're
playing at but many people will read
meaning into it that they want to
strengthen their hands and possibly not
let go but zoom off easily despite
International pressure too for them to
do that
well earlier the head of a group of
Nigerian Scholars told Al Jazeera that
the coup leader in Niger has agreed to
direct talks with regional block echoas
a group of religious leaders from
Nigeria met the military rulers in the
capital of the army the delegation has
called for dialogue to end the crisis
their visit is part of efforts to ease
tensions after the military took power
but my colleague Sami zaidan spoke to
Abdullah the leader of the delegation he
said those talks could happen in the
coming days
we want to create an Avenue whereby the
leaders of uh you know Junta coup in
Niger will have a dialogue with the air
course leaders to understand each other
so that peace will continue to reign in
our region you mentioned there he has
accepted are you are you saying that
abdulrahman the leader of the coup has
accepted to have direct talks with
ecowas
yes he had accepted to have for you that
is you know discussions with the leaders
of you know of course
so we want them to select a place where
to meet
if they intend to meet there in Media or
in Nigeria or where else they think is
better for them then we want a lasting
solution where peace will continue to
rain in our origin that that was why we
were there when do you expect these
talks to take place between abdulrahman
qiani and Equus leaders
yes as soon as we meet with the
president of Nigeria you know first we
met him and we want that intervention to
take place we want him to grant us
audience and he granted audience for us
and he said he agreed if you can go
ahead to intervene so we commend his
effort and as soon as we we we are back
now we are back in Abuja maybe tomorrow
inshallah who will meet him so I don't
want to play empty what we discussed
with the leader of Niger until we have
audience with the president of Nigeria
and later inshallah I know they will fix
time to discuss
well there is mounting concern in West
African states that military
intervention against coup leaders in
Niger would worsen an already difficult
humanitarian and security situation in
the Sahel it's a region that struggles
against armed groups like isil and
Al-Qaeda with thousands killed and
millions forced to flee their homes Al
jazeera's Charles Stratford reports from
Zebula near the Ghana bikini Faso border
these women and children are a tiny
fraction of the more than 5 million
people the UN says have fled attacks by
armed groups across the Sahel region of
West Africa in recent years
they shelter in this Refugee reception
camp near the border between Ghana and
Burkina Faso
lakmeisaya escaped from their Village in
Burkina Faso with her seven children she
describes that day in May
we were on our farm when the shooting
started we tried to run to the Village
but the shooting was too intense as we
ran we saw many dead people we were very
afraid
look me says her children haven't seen
their dad since the day they've fled
we were with my husband when they
started shooting
but we lost him as we ran I don't know
where he is now we hope he's still alive
so he can come here to the calm the
Ghanaian Refugee agency plans to build a
camp for 6 000 more refugees close by
but there is growing concern time may be
running out after the West African
Regional block ecowas threatened niger's
coup Leaders with military intervention
as a last resort if they don't return to
civilian rule
neighboring Burkina Faso along with
Marley have said that any military
intervention in Niger by ecowas would be
a declaration of war on those countries
too
so there are increasing fears that in a
situation like that armed groups like
isil and Al-Qaeda could take advantage
of the situation which could potentially
mean thousands more refugees flooding
into countries like Ghana and others
right the way across the Sahel region
Al authorities say they are preparing
for the worst
we're watching the space and watching to
see what's going to happen we we hope
that it doesn't get worse or as bad as
some people predict but we are we're on
the lookout and we're talking to all the
necessary uh the industry people and the
necessary agencies
armed groups have killed thousands of
people across the Sahel region in recent
years
Echoes says the security situation in
Burkina Faso and Mali deteriorated in
the first six months of this year and
that was before the coup in Niger
neighboring countries already struggling
to cope are braced for potentially
thousands more people fleeing across
borders for their lives Charles
Stratford Al Jazeera near the Ghana
Burkina Faso border